Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're your host of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you.
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Are you awake now?
I hope the Ruffians awake.
Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us today for our 36th episode!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
It's a good way to wake up in the morning, right?
Together with FUWAMOCO Morning and
Some air horns?
Air horns?
Well, maybe there's some first-time Ruffians that are a little bit confused.
This explanation might not fix that, but!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show, and it's held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face,
I hope you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Extra silly today?
This is normal.
You should know now, Ruffians, okay?
Don't make fun of Moco-chan, okay?
What did I say?
Did I?
Don't make fun of me!
You saw Pero, right?
Right Ruffians.
Where is he this time?
What is this?
After last time, I guess I could have expected this.
Well, I don't know.
Pero was bothered working hard at the steel shop last time, right, Ruffians?
So, I guess Pero must have gotten pretty tired, pretty exhausted, and felt like he needed a bit of a vacation.
Why?
Just look at him, you know?
He's melting into the sand!
I don't know, Ruffians, you've been working pretty hard.
We've been working hard too.
Why is it that it's Pero who's vacationing, huh?
Right.
Not very fair, it doesn't seem right at all.
But, I guess, on a different note.
Pineapple drink looks pretty nice.
Is it fresh pineapple juice in it?
Or maybe it's something different?
Maybe it's just water?
Just water.
I don't know.
I only thought that these kind of drinks existed in fantasies, right?
Like, they're not real.
We hope you had a really good time on vacation.
Maybe that Pero's lazy attitude didn't get in the way of your fun too much.
You know, maybe it's a good thing that he's melting into the sand here, huh?
That way.
You don't need to see what kind of swimming gear he's wearing.
Swimming gear, pero swimming gear.
I don't wanna see swimsuit pero.
BAU BAU!
I'm not gonna think about it.
It's too early.
It's too early to think about that.
It's never the right time to think about that.
On to happier things!
In case you haven't heard, Ruffians!
On Friday, it's Kobo-senpai's 3D showcase!
Friday at 6am PST or 10 o'clock JST.
Kobo-senpai from Whole ID will be having her 3D showcase final!
I don't know, Ruffians, you definitely know by now, we're really, really, really excited always for all the 3D showcases.
But, I don't know, this time, I just, I can't wait to see what Kobo-senpai has been planning for me.
Right!
Princess Cowboy!
She has such a beautiful singing voice, so maybe we'll hear her for the song!
Maybe she'll play something on guitar!
But, really, I'm just looking forward to seeing her run around and be sort of crazy.
Crazy, yeah.
Crazy.
We're looking forward to it, Ruffians!
I'm sure it'll be a crazy, silly, fun time.
Good luck, Kobosen!
We'll be cheering you on from the comments.
BAU BAU!
Something might happen.
We don't know what might happen.
I have to watch.
And there's been other happy things going on, you know?
And I think maybe Ruffians, um, maybe, you know?
Do you know what it is?
With all the Halloween excitement that's going around, you know?
We're sure you've been busy, Ruffians.
But you haven't been so busy that you missed this.
Why?
Nerissa!
Nerissa, I do cover of Down by the River.
Yeah!
You didn't miss it, right?
You listened right!
You didn't miss it?
Good!
Good, good!
I can trust you. It's a beautiful song for Baldur's Gate 3. And even if you're not too familiar with the game.
I see.
We'll definitely be really charmed by Nerissa's singing voice.
You know, good songs are always good, right?
Yeah, it's quite different from all the other song covers that she's released so far.
It's a bit more of a ballad.
So you should definitely, definitely go have a listen, or have another listen.
Another listen!
And enjoy the gentle and powerful voice of Nerissa.
It's different from us, yet different from her.
It's different from everything so far.
So you need to!
Why, Shurin?
Why?
I don't know.
We both really enjoy it when Nerissa sings in English, too.
It's so pretty.
Nerissa, congrats on the anniversary!
BAU BAU!
We've also had a little bit of exciting stuff ourselves.
Ruffians!
Right before our spooky rock n' rawr party.
You remember, right?
We gave you a bit of a treat.
I hope they remember.
You remember, right?
You forget?
Yup!
Cheat?
Yes!
No!
The cheat was... New emotes!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
What do you think of them?
Yeah!
You like them?
You forgot it!
Maybe you should try to remember, huh?
I hope you like our Ruffians.
This time I know we have some
What do you think?
I think it's good.
That first one, what do you mean?
There's also some updates to the previous release of emojis.
So now they're a bit easier to see on YouTube.
In case you didn't know, the BAU BAU one's different, right?
Yeah, YouTube's a bit silly and thinks that we all have 20-20 vision and maybe even some of us who do have 20-20 vision can't see that great.
You know, we have a bit of a stronger vision than you, but even then, we have a bit of a hard time too, so hopefully you'll use them a lot and have a bunch of fun with them now too.
Thank you so much to Meo-pon-san!
Meo-pon-san, arigatou!
Ruffians.
Maybe there's some Ruffians that are like, huh?
I can't use them.
If you'd like to be able to use them, you'll have to join our membership.
The Doggy Pack!
Actually, right now is a really great time because we're going to be watching The Shining all together tomorrow.
We've never seen it before, so if you haven't seen it before, then maybe we could share the first The Shining all together.
Good timing.
Good timing?
Yeah.
What do you think?
Good.
You know, maybe right now is a good time.
BAU BAU!
Let's have lots of fun with them, okay?
Actually... Ruffians...
It just so happens to seem like there's a little bit of controversy that's come up.
There's been a petition that's been started because of these emotes.
All these new emotes!
We're just doing our best.
You know, some Ruffians seem to think that it's not very fair, huh?
It's not fair.
Not righteous.
That Fuwawa doesn't seem to have her own sneezing emo.
I understand.
But, Ruffians.
Are you outraged?
Are you upset?
I don't know.
Fuwawa doesn't sneeze.
I do sometimes.
Are you okay?
I'm glad that you're okay.
But it does seem like there are a number of Ruffians who aren't so happy, aren't so okay with it.
And they decided.
But they make a very convincing case using factual evidence and research from Stanford University too.
Yeah, it's very well researched and thought out and put together.
But, I thought, you know, if that's the case, well, maybe we should do something.
Ruffians, what do you think?
Should we?
Do you absolutely, desperately need a Fuwawa sneezing emoji?
It's rare occurrence, okay?
It's not like me!
Moco-chan who hogs all the airtime with your sneezes.
Maybe a bit.
Do things always have to be fair?
Yes, they should be fair, but even for imotsu!
Yes!
Where is my position then?
Don't I need a special strange emote then too?
Nobody's thinking about that.
Balance is needed.
It seems like Ruffians have a lot of different ideas for emotes but...
You have to let us know what you'd like to see more of, okay?
BAU BAU!
I guess let us know what you'd like to see for Imotsu too.
Is there a lot of hololive members that cause controversy with their emotes, Moco-chan?
This isn't good.
We're newbies and everything.
I don't know what this means for the future of FUWAMOCO.
It's uneasy.
Could be rocky, could be rough.
We'll do our best, okay Ruffians?
We'll do our best, we'll do our best.
Ruffians!
There's something exciting that we have to show you!
Something special!
Something exciting!
Ruffians!
You should know.
You shouldn't have forgotten.
We have a bunch of spooky plans for Halloween coming up.
You haven't forgotten.
They involve you.
You need to be there.
We told you.
My voice is not dying, thank you.
I am perfectly good.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
We thought that it'd be really fun to do something special together.
And that's why we'd like to have a... A spooky story time together with you!
Is that okay?
Oh well, we have a plan.
Hello!
We'd like to ask you for your own spooky and silly Halloween stories so that we can read them and enjoy some shivers up our spine all together.
Your own original stories that you write, okay?
We'll be collecting them through a simple Google form, so it's nothing complicated.
But we'd like to ask that your stories contain no other characters from other IPs, that they're completely original and are from
What?
Important.
Yeah.
And are from 250 to 1,000 words in length.
And also, that there's no offensive content in it either, okay?
Yeah, yeah.
BAU BAU!
We can read them and enjoy them all together!
Ruffians, are you excited?
Even if you're not, like, you're like, oh, I don't know if I'm good at writing stories.
Please do!
Yeah!
And you know, spooky and silly is perfect, right?
I know it.
Ruffians!
Maybe we'll write our own stories, too!
We should write it with pen names, too, right, Moco-chan?
Yeah, but Ruffians can't tell.
They'll always be like, This bridge line looks like it was written by Moco-chan!
PG-13?
Yes, please.
But Mofi is really looking forward to having more fun together, creating a special first Halloween night spent all together that we'll never forget!
The deadline, the forum is going to be live very shortly.
Very shortly, right after FUWAMOCO Morning, okay?
But the deadline is on Monday the 30th at 6pm PT.
At our usual streaming time in the evening.
We hope you have a fun time writing and good luck!
You can find the link on Twitter and in the YouTube description below right after this.
We'll do our best writing stories too, okay?
Let's do it all together.
BAU BAU!
Spooky stories.
We've been doing a lot of kawaii dog training recently, so we should have a good place to start.
Hopefully.
Ruffians, you have ideas already!
Start thinking, okay?
Idea beam!
Didn't work.
I didn't want to sound too strong of a beam, because I want the Ruffians to keep their ideas.
Oh, and you want to keep your own too, huh?
Me too, yeah.
Happiness.
But with the happiness, sometimes there's more...
Confusing news.
Confusing!
Disappointing news.
Disappointing!
Maybe a bit of a misunderstanding.
But this time, Ruffians, Fuwawa didn't cause it.
Yes, they did!
We played five levels with both Fubuki-senpai and Poruru-oneechan, right?
We did.
It was a lot of fun.
We were brave, right?
You're proud, right, Ruffians?
What's that professional mode at the prison?
I died, but... But we guessed it.
We guessed it, and that's the good thing, right?
Well, Ruffians.
You know, we tried really hard, but Fubuki-senpai is really good at Phasmophobia, so I wanted to try and make her proud.
So we did our best to help out.
We helped out, right?
We didn't have too many items, so... But it was a little tricky.
But that's not the point.
You know, we saw that some Ruffians thought that I
I, Mococo, said something embarrassing.
But I didn't!
I never say anything embarrassing.
That's Fuwawa's job.
What?
What do you mean?
I didn't say anything embarrassing, okay?
What did I think you said, Moco-chan?
Ruffians.
I. I.
I don't want to repeat it.
But Moco-chan, if you don't explain it to the Ruffians, then the misunderstanding will never be clear.
So Ruffians thought that I said Fuwawa onee-chan.
But...
What I really said was, Fuwawa wa onee-chan dakara, or that's because Fuwawa is my older sister.
You just didn't hear the wa, because it's Fuwawawawai.
Fuwawawawai.
Yeah, I wasn't calling her affectionately, so don't misunderstand the case.
Could you please call me affectionately?
No!
Wow, ah, but Moco-chan, the one thing that's been kind of bugging me though... Is you okay with how I ported the cassette by porting to onee-chan, right?
It's different.
But, but... It's different, okay!
But you turned down her marriage offer?
Yeah.
She's my older sister now, so...
If she wanted to get married, she should have said something before she became my older sister, so... That was her choice.
You get it now, right, Ruffians?
It's good!
You're not misunderstanding!
No misunderstandings.
I heard you right, and that's why I wasn't super duper happy or anything, so... I'm glad you weren't happy, why?
But you could say FUWAMO-oneechan again, why?
No!
And you say it again on the Ruffians, why?
That's not how it works!
I'm not gonna say it.
I'm not disappointed at all, no?
Misunderstanding understood.
Logic is good.
Not confused, you understand now!
Understood.
It is the spooky time of month again.
It's almost the end of it.
And I guess the Ruffians could maybe use a little pick- Oh, a pick-me-up.
I didn't get excited.
Sorry!
I wanted to say something.
Ruffians!
Hello!
It's me!
It's Mococo!
Can you hear me?
Can you hear me from the other side?
I'm here!
To speak directly to you!
Yes!
It's another Mococo Pup Talk!
And this time, you're gonna hear from me!
Mococo!
Spooky!
It's almost time for Halloween!
And you might be feeling a bit of spooky appetite!
Has there been too many scary sights?
Too many decorations giving you a jump in the night?
Has it been too dark for you?
I feel the same.
Core dog training can be tough.
But it's Wednesday!
And Halloween is almost here!
That means spooky training can calm down soon!
But, maybe some treats still await you at the end of the month!
BAU!
You can survive the spooky times!
You're doing great no matter what scares you!
And, maybe, FUWAMOCO will give you some extra treats as well!
Just because you're doing your best!
We will survive all the jump scares we have to go through!
Okay!
BAU!
Did I get you?
Don't worry!
It may be scary, but we're here for you!
Ganbatte da!
BAU BAU!
Was it spooky?
Spooky.
Spooky pup talk.
Yeah.
It's definitely been a very spooky month.
Even sometimes going on a walk, I get spooky vibes behind my door.
This is kind of like that game, right?
Next!
Doggie of the Day.
Not spooky!
Not spooky.
Today, we have a very cute Doggie of the Day.
De-den!
Canelo!
Here she is in a very cute costume.
I should say a very super cool costume.
We love how she loves to talk to you.
She was a wonderful girl.
She's dressed up as a rocker here, but I don't know.
I sort of feel like it looks like she's taking a rock and rawr party to heart!
Because this looks like her daily clothing, you know?
I think it fits her well.
Right?
It fits her that well.
But, you know what?
It sort of reminds me of someone.
Maybe she looks kind of rough.
Kind of tough.
Like me.
Ah, me too.
Very cute!
How does she BAU BAU?
I think, you know, while wearing this cool costume, she has a bit more like a roar to her.
A roar?
A roar to her BAU BAU.
BAU BAU?
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU.
It sounds like a bike.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
Although she's no longer in this world with us, we can see just how much she loved you and how gentle and loving and adorable she was.
We're sure she's still watching very closely over you and is looking forward to the next costume you'll have for her too.
BAU BAU!
It's such a beautiful flower.
Oh, there's like a painting even too.
What a cutie.
Well, today's walk.
Did a Ruffian go on a walk?
Ruffians even going on walks?
Even walking, right?
Let's see.
De-den!
It's so orange!
That's a beautiful sunset.
That's the kind of sunset that would make us just keep on walking and walking and walking and walking until the sun is barely visible.
It's too gorgeous.
It's so nice.
I would have to jump out of my seat and go outside.
Especially look at the water too.
I feel like I can almost hear the sounds from the picture.
Right?
It's just like...
So calming, so relaxing.
Need to walk more?
You should!
You're missing out on this!
It's outside!
I feel like these Ruffians are very lucky.
I'm sure this was such a nice walk after work.
Maybe you felt a little bit refreshed too.
Maybe just a little bit.
BAU BAU!
Well, a Question of the Day.
Ruffians, you still have questions, so we have answers!
De-den!
Question.
Question to FUWAMOCO.
What if FUWAMOCO woke up with switched bodies someday?
What if?
Switching bodies?
Are you sure you haven't been watching too many movies?
I don't know.
Interesting question.
This isn't really something we've thought about seriously.
Zombie apocalypse is... Yes?
Yes, we've thought about that seriously.
I think the Ruffians know the answer to that.
We know our plan there, but... This?
Our plan!
Yeah, our plan.
I don't know.
Maybe things will just go the same?
The same way?
I don't know.
I mean, we have to wear different clothes, but...
I think probably nothing will really change my... Maybe that's not a good answer though.
Maybe it's a bad answer.
What about you, Ruffians?
Do you have any suggestions?
What do you think we should do?
That's weird thoughts.
I missed you!
Can we try swapping right now?
No, that would be an on-air accident.
That's right, I guess I would sneeze some more.
I guess in that case we definitely need to have a Fuwawa sneezing emo, huh?
Maybe then.
I don't know, I think I just want to go back to normal ASAP.
We have to, we should change our name.
Why?
Why is it that when you're in my body then we change the name order, huh?
I don't know.
Ruffians, cool it.
I would want to go back ASAP.
Yeah, I feel uncomfortable too.
Yeah.
Why so rough?
I'd be the cherished younger sister.
It's just my body.
I guess my body is a bit younger then.
What?
I had a nice dream, but the Ruffians are being silly.
Nevermind!
Thank you!
I'm sorry!
Do it!
Well, Ruffians, we want to say thank you so much for all your submissions today.
And not just today, always, too.
Remember...
FUWAMOCO Morning is something that we make together, so we need you to continue sending your submissions!
We need you!
Thank you!
We're always looking and keeping our eyes open for your Doggie of the Day!
I'd like to see what kind of walks you're going on!
I'd like to receive your questions!
And also Pero Sightings too!
Keep your eyes open for Pero, okay?
Yes, yes.
I'll do my best.
Don't forget to use the hashtag FUWAMOCO Morning.
FWMCMORNING, okay?
Hashtag.
FWMCMORNING.
Hashtag a hashtag?
Yes!
It's a word and then it's a hashtag.
It makes sense.
BAU BAU!
At our next stream!
Ah, wow.
Ruffians, today is Wednesday!
Do you know what that means?
Wednesday, it means it's Resident Evil Wednesday!
So, today we'll be playing Resident Evil 4, but it's actually the last Resident Evil Wednesday.
It's a bit sad, but we're gonna have a lot of fun today!
And we're gonna continue, just maybe not so much on Wednesdays.
Yeah.
Fine.
But, we just entered the castle together with Ashi, right?
And our voice are dangerously low, right?
That's Moco-chan, that's your fault.
That's not my issue.
That's Leon's issue.
But hopefully...
It'll be okay.
No problems.
Just issues.
Just issues, yeah.
Let's get Ashley back to safety!
So that she can see her dad again.
I wonder what Ashley's dad looks like.
Let's take another look at our schedule We have a very spooky, spooky and busy weekend before Halloween here We're gonna be playing Devour all together with Avid this week
BAU BAU
They seem pretty scared.
They seem very concerned.
Do you think we'll survive, Ruffians?
I don't know.
This could be our scariest game yet.
You think we'll be okay?
Definitely spooky.
Definitely not scary.
Which one is it?
We'll do our best!
Abbey will be there so we can depend on them, right?
And we'll also be continuing Home Sweet Home together with Biboo on her channel!
BAU BAU!
So, we were doing some testing.
Because we've been very busy.
We haven't been able to play Suica game recently.
No, me sleeping is more important.
I might have done something to Suica game Ruffians.
I paused it though.
Can you guess what I did?
Oh no, oh no.
I... It might be very close to getting a double Suica.
Very close.
I beat my score.
And it's still going.
It's still going.
It was just one test.
It wasn't even multiple rounds.
It was just a, oh, is this still working sort of thing.
Yeah.
So, I paused it so that we could get the double Suica together, okay?
We haven't been playing though.
But we want to do it together, okay?
Please wake up early and let's grow two Suica together, okay?
One Suica can be mine and the other can be yours.
Whatever we need.
Nothing for Moco-chan.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, today's FUWAMOCO Morning is coming to an end, but we'd like to thank you once more for waking up early and joining us here today.
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians!
Maru Storm!
BAU BAU!
Full Bliss!
Take-chan.
BAU BAU!
Finn.
Daiya.
BAU BAU!
Reddish Leaflet.
Noda.
BAU BAU!
Josuke.
Cats Monjo.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!